mark Perry why a book about grant and
Twain so it's a good question it's two
friendships but there have been other
friendships in the 19th century but this
is a particularly interesting one a war
hero and a man who abhorred war a man of
an older generation a great generation
that it saved America reunited it lets
makes for a fascinating story the
interplay between basically America's
first celebrity Mark Twain and and at
the time a person many people thought
was the greatest American who ever lived
where did you get the idea
20 years ago I was editing a newspaper
here in Washington called City paper and
there was the 100th anniversary of the
writing of Huckleberry Finn and I
happened to be reading grants memoirs at
the same time and it just both of them
just stuck with me I thought there's
real similarities here and so I began to
investigate the friendship and through
20 years of work finally at the end my
agent said oh just do the book so I I
did it where did you get your interest
in either Huckleberry Finn or in reading
grants memoir well I've always been
interested in nineteenth-century
American history it seems to me to be
the formative period in our history
especially focusing on the issues of
race and slavery and did a lot of
scholarship on it and studied the Civil
War and of course in the 1970s 1980s
this was the euro when Shelby Foote was
writing his masterpiece is three-volume
masterpiece and so I became caught up in
it this is now my my third book on the
era it's always been a I guess a
lifelong passion page 235u right
americans love nonfiction we are a
nation consumed by politics and history
if Twain as Hemingway proposes wrote the
quintesson quintessential American novel
then grant his friend wrote the single
most important work of fiction in our
literature it's really from Edmund
Wilson I Oh Edmund will sell a lot our I
think our greatest literary critic and
commentator on
American nonfiction who said was Edmund
Wilson really gave me the idea that
nonfiction is an American genre he wrote
a book on civil war literature called
patriotic gore it's been very
influential in all of my works and he
pointed to the grant memoir as a great
piece of nonfiction and quoted Twain
saying that it was like unto Caesar's
commentaries and for our greatest
arguably I think it is debatable for our
greatest work of nonfiction grants
memoirs to be written in the same year
as Huckleberry Finn which is probably
our greatest work of fiction is is quite
extraordinary there other things written
at the same time the Bostonians and
William Dean Howells was alive in
writing these these were really
extraordinary books and an extraordinary
literary period it's not really focused
on I don't think enough in our in our
history when did Mark Twain first meet
as you say Sam grant yes was a prior to
was prior to Grant's becoming president
but after the Civil War and it was at a
reception and they were standing
together they were introduced of course
Twain was not then as famous as he was
to become but he was getting there he
was a celebrity and they were introduced
to each other very uncomfortably stood
there in silence and Twain turned to
grant and said I'm very uncomfortable
aren't you and grant laughed and I think
it was Twain's bluntness and Grant's
self-effacement that really fit well
together their paths crossed then later
on after the grant presidency when grant
was being introduced the Palmer House in
Chicago is this was typical 19th century
late-night whiskey and cigars men
sitting around for hours and hours of
speeches it was it was their late-night
television and grant gave a 2 a.m. in
the morning speech introducing between
gave a 2 a.m. in the morning speech
introducing grant and really ripped up
the audience was quite funny making fun
of grant and quite worried that grant
would take it
wrong he didn't and their friendship
develop from there they became very fast
friends in the period that I talked
about 1884 1885 and I think they had a
special relationship what year did grant
died he died July 1885 just just after
finishing his memoirs just two weeks
after finishing his memoirs in northern
New York State and the country knew that
he was going to die there were always
reports that someone would recover live
on Grant Twain thought that he would
live for several more months but if it
was clear that after he finished his
memoirs he he threw in the towel he was
all finished July 1895 when did that was
grant when did Twain die early 1900s in
fact and Haley's the night of Halley's
Comet in America generation two
generations later but the the important
thing I think about the rest of Twain's
life the thing that seems to be true
about Twain's later life is that after
Huckleberry Finn and after the death of
Grant he really he wrote several other
very good books but he never had the
same kind of literary power as he did
when Grant was alive and he kept
returning to his friendship with Grant
in his journals over and over and over
again this is a man who wrote tens of
thousands of words on on grant trying to
figure them out and trying to understand
their relationship what is in the grant
memoir if you read it well it's the
story it's a story of the first chapters
of the story of his family and his
growing up in Ohio and his education
there are one or two chapters on the
Mexican War in his time as a young
soldier in the Mexican War but the real
the balance of the book and the power of
the book is in his recounting of his
Civil War commands from the first
battles and to the surrender at
Appomattox and then he was very intent
to write an epilogue on
he thought it meant but he thought the
war meant and what his hopes were the
country where he did not historians
think unfortunately he did not focus on
his presidency at all this is a memoir
of his wartime experience what is an
Huckleberry Finn what's the story
Huckleberry Finn we think is most
Americans know is a story of a young boy
Huck and a runaway slave Jim and their
journey to freedom but there's an oddity
in Huckleberry Finn at the end of
chapter 16 Huck and Jim are at the
confluence of the Ohio River and the
Mississippi River if they take a left if
they go east of the Ohio they go to
freedom and Jim is free and if they go
south they go further into slave
territory and Jim would still be a slave
if captured Twain wanted to take these
two characters down the Mississippi but
why would he do that why would you go
further in a slave territory this is the
end of chapter 16 of Huckleberry Finn
and so in 1876 after writing very
quickly the first 16 chapters of
Huckleberry Finn he puts the manuscript
down it's clear that he's he's reached
an impasse he doesn't know how to
continue the book and that's what I
focus on the book is his solution to
that problem whether to take Huck and
Jim south or whether to take them up the
Ohio River if a picture in here of Mark
Twain with John T Lewis yes when was it
taken
who was it this is John T Lewis's a as a
helper servant in Elmira New York and a
very close friend of of Twain's and the
pattern for Jim the model for Jim Twain
enjoyed Lewis's talk of the old country
of what his life had been like this was
a very intelligent
and who was who as a who was very close
to Twain and remained so through his
whole life as you can see by the picture
very a very dignified man it's very
clear that between Pat earned a lot of
Jim on on what on what this gentleman
had to tell him at some point your book
you say make no bones about it the
publishing world is all about one thing
money and also you point out in your
book throughout that Grant was broke at
one point and Mark Twain ended up
bankrupt yeah they're similar in that
respect here are two men of two
different generations and it seems odd
to us now in their time the Gilded Age
the euro right after the Civil War both
are very concerned about money the great
captains of industry of their time are
the most revered americans of vanderbilt
n' and people from of the great
corporate families and they both looked
up to these gentlemen they both wanted
to accumulate money it was the standard
of excellence for their time and grant
was president the United States and Mark
Twain was one of America's great writers
and here they both were really
fascinated by money Twain never earned
enough publishing his books to become
the rich man that he wanted to become
and he knew this so he would always
invest in very strange projects the the
project that broke him that bankrupted
him at the end of his life was a page
typesetter he spent years trying to
develop it and didn't work out grant on
the other hand became part of a great
Wall Street firm of Grant and Ward he
just simply let his name to it and it
went bankrupt 1884 just prior to his
becoming sick so both men reached out
for money and neither man really
we're able to get that dream of great in
many ways very sad story I think that
they were I think they were misled by
this pursuit of money the grant could
have lived very comfortably after his
presidency if he'd just let well enough
alone
but his investments in this firm and the
fraud that was visited on him by the
firm's leaders was one of the real great
disappointments of his life and Twain
had the same problem how many homes did
US grant have given to him well there
was one in I Street in Washington there
was one in Philadelphia there was one in
Galena Illinois there are probably more
at least four homes that were given to
him as subscriptions by his great and
good and wealthy friends as a thanks
from them to him for what he'd done for
his country and he stayed basically
rent-free in a home in Long Branch New
Jersey because of a friendship that he
developed with a with a publisher in
Philadelphia he did not then at the end
of his presidency have a pension but it
was very clear that his good friends
were more than willing to take care of
him and and see to it that he prospered
how did he get this the home at 66th
Street in New York City it was a
subscription from a group of friends
raised thousands and thousands of
dollars it was a beautiful three floors
he sat in the front room of this of this
home when he went bankrupt he went
through the home and took everything out
of it his medallions his swords his even
his uniform the he had gone on a world
tour and had been given gifts from
Sultan's and Kings and he gathered them
all up and and and basically tried to
pawn him off to his friend mr.
Vanderbilt and and who wouldn't take him
didn't want to take ended up taking him
and lending him money so that he could
see through day to day
but all of those all of his other homes
and all of his properties had property
in st. Louis was sold to meet his debts
and even then his debts were not met he
vowed to repay every dollar he was a he
was a good and honorable man but in in
1884 when grant award went bankrupt in
the marine bank and Brooklyn closed as a
result of it couldn't mean its deaths
there were there were a lot of people in
New York City thousands of people who
lost a great deal of money in grant Ward
and for him to repay all of it would
have been nearly impossible but he did
his best and at the same time he had to
take care of his uh his wife primarily
ninis and his children and retrieve his
reputation this was foremost in his mind
he say he was honorable man he had pride
know that if he had so much pride why
did he take all those homes from people
he was a he was a he was a complex
character eat I grant is one of the
great enigmas I think of American
history a lot of historians have been
more biographies of Grant recently than
you could count he was modest
self-effacing soft-spoken absolutely
determined he did he did take the homes
he had given up his pension in the army
he didn't necessarily think it was his
due but he was in circles where people
would would do things for him there is
no imputation note that I can find in
his presidency that he returned such
favors politically but certainly his he
wasn't the first American to sell his
name and the grant name had great cachet
then and and he and he used that it's a
I don't think it's dishonest did the
last thing that I think ulysses s grant
was was dishonest but he understood who
he was he understood that he was a
public figure and he knew that he could
use that for for his own advancement and
did in the end
did he actually complete the memoir
before he died and and and then who got
the money and how much money did the
book generate he finished his memorial
before he died a month but Gregor in New
York where he had been taken in the
advice of doctors for his last days to
the air was cleaner and it did seem to
revive him where he is mountain
MacGregor said in northern New York it's
north of just north of Saratoga Springs
in upstate New York
beautiful have you been there oh yes did
you go to the house where he was yes who
owned that house this was a house of a
of a businessman in New York who had put
together a syndicate of owners who
bought out the original farmstead of a
MacGregor who wanted to set up a resort
never was able to make it go and they
thought that they would be able to do it
and they built a hotel there and
advertised it and they the Philadelphia
businessman who led this syndicate of
investors and purchased this land
thought it'd be great to have grant
there that it eventually would bring
more and more visitors and more and more
tourists to Mount McGregor so he he lent
them he lent the grants this house and
the doctor said this would be perfect to
clear up the congestion and Grant's
throat in the cancer and let him breathe
easier and sleep better and it did for a
time and he went there left his home in
New York and end of June beginning of
July of 1885 and went to mob MacGregor
and they had a cabin there form and he
enjoyed it he would eat up the nearby
hotel at such as it was he couldn't eat
easily because of his cancer but he
would be able to Balmoral and there was
an honor guard there and he he
immediately went back to work on his
memoirs they should have been complete
by now he had finished all of the major
workers his memoirs but in the last two
or three weeks of his life he really
plunged on into that epilogue that he
wanted to write and he wanted to do as
he said tidy up some different parts of
the manuscript so he did that
and then as he was sitting on his porch
one day and he would always wear a wool
cap and a scarf and he'd be sitting in
his chair and he had a blanket over him
he turned to Dawson his to [ __ ] and
said I'm done and it was approximately
two weeks a little bit less after that
that his health failed precipitously
need I'd originally ask you how much
money his wife lived 19 years after he
died Julia yeah there's much money in
the family well is that it's not clear
but it's over four hundred thousand
dollars the original check that that the
Twain gave Julia was two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars and there was
another two hundred thousand dollars
after that and that time it was an
enormous amount of money and we never I
double checked in and and I don't don't
hold me to this but on today's dollar
it's about eight million dollars yes
extraordinary amount of money did the
world know that he made that much money
back then and how many books did he sell
the book came out in subscription and it
was a it was two volumes I'm not really
sure how many had sold 60,000 70,000 an
incredible number for that time a
best-seller even in our time four
hundred fifty thousand dollars eight
million I hadn't realized it was that
much money so that's a lot it was a lot
of money and it kept Julia in the style
to which she was accustomed for the rest
of her life
and it made Twain a lot of money to
which he then subsequently
frittered away but it was an
extraordinary amount of money as Wilson
says as Edmund Wilson says in patriotic
gore every northern home would have the
twin volumes like pillars of grants
memoirs in a prominent place in their
living room as a as a sign of their
patriotism the Union cause this sold by
subscription door-to-door sales was
extraordinarily popular book now explain
that because that is an issue all
through the book subscription versus
book store sales yes how does that work
as Twain would say you never make any
money selling in the trade that is
selling to a publisher and he puts in
the book store
and he had terrible terrible time
getting publishers to do what he wanted
them to do and to distribute the way he
wanted them to distribute and push the
book and advertise the book they never
seem to do it enough that was true of
life on the Mississippi and he was just
very embittered about it he was always
he always thought he could do it better
he thought that about almost every
business enterprise that he was involved
in and so he would he would hire
Canvassers and he and his nephew Charles
Webster Charlie hired canvassers for
Huckleberry Finn and for the memoirs and
would give them promotional material and
divide up the country into sections
where the book could be sold and send
them out and when there were enough
copies sold of the book then they then
they would publish it that is when it
had made enough money to cover its costs
and a little profit in their time then
they would publish it the interesting
thing about Huckleberry Finn is that it
was its publication date is 1884 but it
really didn't get into the hands of its
customers its readers until February
1885 because Twain wouldn't allow it
he said we're going to sell 50,000 this
before we publish and that was
subscription sales that's now almost
unheard of this was at the early
development of the real Giants and
publishing scriveners and and and other
publishers and they hadn't really taken
hold to the degree that they are now
subscription publishing was not
Universal but it was come as you know
your book sells for $25 and if you the
way it works today that the bookstore
keeps half yeah that's right and but
they don't usually sell it full price
and but the publisher gets half what
would have been an in a subscription
basis oh the percentages were much
better you know it's what then it was it
wasn't cheap to to publish in print a
book but it was compared to the to the
cost it is now was relatively cheaper
you could you could publish a book
fairly cheaply and and and make money on
it the printing process
was longer the distribution process was
much more difficult than it is now it
was you know it's difficult than to sell
a book in Peoria Illinois compared to
now or even or even Chicago there were
there just wasn't this these huge
bookstores you sold in New York you sold
in San Francisco you sold in Washington
Philadelphia and those were the huge
proportion sales to get out of the
countryside you really didn't need
Canvassers and subscriptions and today
you can get both Huck Finn and grants
memoir free on the Internet
yeah hole you can get it almost in any
bookstore I was I was in a one of our
chain bookstores yesterday and there
were the memoirs and there was Huck Finn
they've been in print now for 120 years
so the Mississippi what did the
Mississippi what was about the
Mississippi and what was grants
relationship to the Mississippi what was
Twain's relationship to the Mississippi
River
yeah well it's it we call then more so
than now was the great art artery of
American commerce and industry it was
the the real backbone that the engineer
of the frontier it was that during when
Twain was growing up and when he was a
pilot on the Mississippi and it was that
for for grant when he also as a boy went
down to Mississippi this was it was
hugely important in terms of Commerce
for Twain it was also a touchstone
throughout his whole life he'd grown up
on the river it had meant everything to
him everything in his early life as a
boy was defined by the river or was he
born well he was born in he was born in
Hannibal Missouri he was born in Florida
Missouri and then moved to Hannibal
Missouri his father was a judge so he
was white it was right on the river the
whole time born Samuel Clemens yes when
did he change his name he changed his
name when he became a pilot changed his
name and they changed his name after
became a pilot he became when he became
a writer and he had to write he thought
it would be better for him to write
under another name this is especially
true in Nevada when he was doing
some really tongue-in-cheek reporting
and he'd had a model to this this was an
era when the really admired writers in
America were the were the satirist and
he wanted to be a satirist and he wanted
to also to model himself we would say
now I suppose brand himself as a person
of the frontier a person of the
Mississippi recalled himself Mark Twain
1868 1869 he made the changeover
where do you get the name he gave he got
the name from the call of the of the
Watchmen on the steamboat that would
yell out the depth of where the
steamboat was and Mark Twain was I can't
remember now how many feet it was but it
was passable feet where you where the
water was open and free it caught Mark
Twain and it was was something that
stuck with him stuck the difference in
age between Mark Twain and Ulysses just
a generation 15 19 years in 19 years and
in age who was older Oh grant was older
the older generation that that commanded
the war Twain was of the generation that
fought the war on the front lines you
mentioned earlier at home in Galena
Illinois but also something called
hardscrabble near st. Louis what was
that hardscrabble was a grant left the
army under really controversial
circumstances he was away from his wife
whom he just julia homemade adored
couldn't live without her he was on the
west coast near resigned came east and
his father-in-law gave him peace of land
to to farm and they called it
hardscrabble he built a a one-room cabin
and broke the soil himself back-breaking
work he had two hands to help him slaves
and didn't like farming thought that he
could make a go of it couldn't ended up
legendary incident from a civil war
colleagues said that he saw him one day
on the streets of st. Louis
in cordwood he was flat dead broke
finally he swallowed his pride went back
up to Galena and worked in his father's
leather goods store he couldn't stand
when his father was a Tanner it's a
dirty dirty business curing the hides
and throwing the hides it makes you
stronger but it's you're covered with
blood animal blood he hated it
so he thought he could make a living in
his father's dry goods store as a clerk
didn't like that either and wasn't very
good at it
and the Civil War came along and he
helped to organize Illinois volunteer
regiments and went off and became a
great soldier how many places did you go
in search of oh these two men um
everywhere um Hartford where Twain lived
still has the big house there still is
the big house beautiful you know you get
a real sense of Twain when you walk in
the door of his Hartford home he built
it the way he wanted to with even a you
know an outer cupola that looks like a
steamboat cabin the billiard room was
the most number of servants he ever had
oh he had nurses for his children he had
tutors for his children he had cooks for
his wife he had the manservant for
himself he spent an enormous amount of
money on the house and on the servants
and then living the way that he thought
a great writer should live and he would
complain about it in his journals on
occasion and Intel Howells that the
house was sucking up every penny that he
had but he wanted to live there and he
lived he lived in what was then the
literary capital of the United States
Hartford who is Howells
William Dean Howells was the was the
editor of the Atlantic Monthly Magazine
and probably the leading arbiter of
literary tastes did he buy his fiction
he did he bought his fiction he but as
si as he was a very good friend here was
the one William Dean Howells is really
an extraordinary
writer in his own right who
unfortunately not remembered as well as
he should be now but he would he would
commiserate with Twain and he would lend
him advice I think is probably the only
person outside of Twain's wife Livi that
would really listen that he could really
give advice to I mean Twain admired
Howells
and it and admired his judgment in
Howells became the arbiter of of
literary taste and Twain knew how
valuable he was they were very good for
who else lived around Hartford Harriet
Beecher Stowe and one of her sisters
Harriet Beecher Stowe the author of
Uncle Tom's Cabin was a icon in American
literature Uncle Tom's Cabin was
exploded on literary America in the late
1850s and it for the North defined the
way that slavery was she lived in
Hartford right next door and did they
know each other they did did they like
each other um Harry Beecher Stowe was
then becoming elderly and a little
crotchety and strange in her old age she
would invade the Twain's back yard and
rip out the flowers and then appear at
the front door of the Twain's with the
flowers in her hand so I've gotten you
flowers while they were pulled from the
Twain garden Twain said that she used to
walk up behind people in scream give a
banshee scream and scare the living
daylights out of them she was she is
obviously suffering from the effects of
old age and was not on her best behavior
Twain admired I think between really
admired Harriet Beecher Stowe where else
did you go besides Hartford
oh let's see Hartford Elmira New York
just for a day and Hannibal and Galena
the one place that I've always wanted to
see because it had featured in some of
my earlier books and was a great resort
at the time we're all ex presidents and
Larry figures congregated in summers
long branch in New Jersey was quite
different than I thought it would be
it's
it's not the resort it was and it's not
talked about the New York papers it was
but I just wanted to see it so for
Garfield I where Garfield died were the
where the Grimm Keys lived for quite
some time do you do a book on the Grimm
case I did it was called lift up thy
voice about several years ago who were
they
Grimm keys were two sisters the Grimm
keys were a South Carolina family in
which there were two sisters Sarah and
Angelina who had seen slavery up close
and they left South Carolina and came
north and became I think the two most
powerful intellectual influences in the
anti-slavery movement extraordinary
extraordinary women and then later
adopted their brothers offspring from a
liaison with a slave woman and these two
young men african-american men became
also leaders of the black community in
the late 19th century a really
incredible family very torn by the issue
of slavery and race what's the name of
that book lift up thy voice what year Oh
four years ago three years ago back to
that house 1899 is there an I Street
house of grant still left in this town
and is there a 66 Street house left in
New York 66 Street house is gone well
the I Street house is not here either
and both cities have changed
substantially there is a there is a
monument in memorial poen I went to I
went to his tomb in New York I'm on
Riverside Drive really an extraordinary
place and not well visited but we're
seeing that was built for him and I
think at the time people believed that
it would be a gathering place a real
Monument that later generations would go
to it is not that it's it's beautiful
and it's well kept up but when I was
there there weren't many visitors how
long did he actually work on his memoir
actually it was a relatively short
period of time two years for the
extraordinary amount of work that I was
and the thousands of were in it and it's
a long it is a long book but it's
fascinating it was a very short time he
would he would write he would take notes
he would also dictate which meant that
he had to speak clearly and in and in
complete sentences and then after the
dictation was done he would he would
edit so in all it was 16 to 18 months
beginning to end he was also writing at
the same time a series of articles for
the century magazine for articles on his
campaigns during the civil war so he
integrated those into the book brilliant
but it's a brilliant it's a brilliant
piece of writing and he the reason that
I think he was able to do it in such a
short period of time I think it's a
short period of time took me here and a
half to write this book is that he he
worked ceaselessly um sometimes 20 hours
a day couldn't sleep because of his the
pain from his cancer let me ask you
about that when did he first know
something was wrong with his throat I
was the summer in Long Branch in 1884
and he was eating a peach and I was
cutting it up at the table and Julia was
nearby his wife was nearby and he
swallowed it in the pain just seared
through him he knew something was wrong
in the back of his throat but he didn't
he didn't go to anybody for it he he
went later on in the summer to a to a
doctor recommended by a friend from
Philadelphia the publisher then in
October he went he went to New York City
and saw his doctor and the doctor
immediately knew that it was
I guess the word is empathy meal in
nature a cancer the back of the throat
and the tongue that it was spreading and
then it was probably fatal and he was
sent to another expert doctor shreddy
who who took what we would call a biopsy
now took a scraping from the back of the
throat and studied it he didn't tell the
original doctor didn't tell dr. shreddy
who the patient was and the doctor said
well this is this is from the throat of
General Grant and tradie said well then
general Grant's a dead man it was so
untreatable the time and it spread
quickly and made grant made difference
wallowing very difficult for Grandma and
the doctor that he chose to treating
throughout the whole thing was dr. John
Douglas a UH a really interesting
character and a very compassionate in
tone and in then good man
a person who stayed by a side and
conductor and doctor shreya was there
also there were three doctors there who
often showed great compassion for him I
think it was dr. Schrader I went into
the book who actually held him rocked
him to sleep and then asked mrs. grant
whether that would be embarrassing to
the general and she said oh no not at
all so they were they were with them
much of the time and and in treating him
with cocaine laudanum painkillers here's
an image that you give us in the book
here is the general of the Civil War and
the prezi knighted States for two terms
leaving his 66th Street home and getting
on the subway or the trolley car
whatever was to go to the doctor's
officer Reid come every day yeah he did
did he have any Secret Service
protection no no no surprising to me too
I remember an incident
I guess it was in footsore narrative of
grant walking from the White House the
telegraph office of people passing them
on the street and saying good morning
mr. president well there was no Secret
Service there was no he was there was no
sense that he could ever be in danger
he would he would go with a with a
manservant or a friend and get on the
trolley and sit and go to the doctors
and or take a carriage finally his
family insisted the doctors come to see
him because he was getting a lot weaker
you get a picture in here about Minister
this fellow right here yeah who is he
and what role did he play in this story
John Philip Newman the Reverend John
Philip Newman a Methodist minister and
very close to Julia his wife Julia was a
very strong and devout believing
Christian woman grant was a little bit
less so but the Reverend Newman intruded
himself on the family from time to time
would sit with grant and in one incident
at the end of the day when they were all
eating dinner in Newman stayed and he
gave a he gave grace before the meal and
he went on and on and on and on
finally he finished saying grace and
grant yelled out Amen he was wanted eat
and Newman interpreted this as a sign of
grants great devotion to religion grant
had never been baptized wasn't baptized
until April the year he died at Julia's
insistence he tolerated Newman Newman
believed that he had been sent to save
grant that to cure the cancer God would
cure the cancer and that grants great
faith in Christianity and in God would
be assembled to the American people
that faith could cure anything grant was
a great skeptic just an incredible
skeptic he was tolerant of Newman and
very patient with embodied he just
wasn't that kind of person
grants doctors barely tolerated the
minister did his thing outside of the
house with a press well how many people
would in the press would stand across
the street and watch the kind of like a
dozen dozens at first there were there
were dozens and then they strung a wire
from across the street and they would
assign a couple Pressman down the block
to another house where a whole bunch of
press this was a this was a Death Watch
Grant was the story in the country for
many many months and and the doctors and
the grand family decided early on that
they just weren't going to talk to the
press that much that there really wasn't
that much to say and that this was
Grant's private business and he was
writing a book and so the press would
come out from the press then was a lot
different than that will come out with
these updates day to day and Newman took
full advantage of this and came out when
Grant had had a medical crisis and came
out and told the press General Grant
held my hand and said thrice have I been
so long with rice have I been to the
valley of death and thrice have I
conquered it and between wrote in his
journal sha know what there's no way
that grant would ever say that and I say
in the book grant would no more use the
word thrice than Huck Finn would say the
Lord's Prayer is just not the kind of
person he was so here was a John Philip
Newman was one of these hangers-on that
was tolerated by Grant but the stories
did come out to Deb from the minister
that he was going to live and he's going
to get better he was going to get better
he's going to live he was gonna conquer
cancer that his belief in God was going
to conquer cancer and Newman was
heartbroken and crestfallen when that's
not the way it turned out in your book
you get the impression that century
magazine folks are going to publish the
grant memoir when does Mark Twain pull
the rug out from under him and why pulls
the rug out from under his right eye why
and what year well this was this was a
long branch in 1884
official senior editors of of the
century magazine have been trying for
some time to get grant to write articles
for their magazine and he'd finally
agreed to do it and it was an
extraordinary stroke of luck he wrote a
very short piece and it wasn't
exceptional and the editor of the
century magazine came back to him and
kind of showed him how to do it and what
he wanted and got him to talking about
it and then they began talking about the
memoirs and grant was very interested
than in doing it having been bankrupted
and they were almost to an agreement
almost to an agreement and it was a was
when grant came back and from Long
Branch in October
tween was in New York and overheard a
conversation among a group of Century
editors as he was walking back from one
of the lectures saying we've got grants
we've got grant signed up and Twain went
the very next day and there was as
legend would have it I think from fact
would have it as his son has written
about it
he was poised to write the contract to
the century magazine and Twain said
don't do it let me just take a look at
the contract looked at the contract
anyone ah they're not giving you very
much money I can give you $25,000 right
now so no no make it $50,000 and Grant
said I can't do that I think I promised
the centrum they came up with the idea
and and Twain said you remember years
ago that I came to you with William Dean
Howells and we talked about your memoir
so by rights it's mine I came up with
the idea and grant said well that's true
enough he said all right I'll tell you
what let me and then grant did what he
should have done when he was a grant
Ward he actually hired a lawyer and to
look over the contract and grant and
Twain wrote him a new contract and went
back on tour but the book was clearly
going to be twins and then in February
grant signed the contract with
with twins so publishing firm Twain did
pull the grip pull the rug out from the
century comes they thought they had it
and he dissuaded Graham to go the other
way you say that
Mark Twain did not offer criticism or a
critique of any kind to us granted
during this process that's right why
because the book was so good um did he
ever ask did grant ever ask for help the
grant was always it's very clear that
grant was worried about what Twain
thought about the book and Twain Twain
thought it was good so he never said
anything he never went to Grant said
house is an extraordinary book he never
thought he had to and finally lay was
Fred grant came to Twain and said gee
it'd be nice if he said something to my
father about the book and tie it so what
do you mean he said well you like it and
he good and in Twain in his journals
recounts I was as surprised as the cook
would be of Columbus asked him how to
navigate he thought it was an
extraordinary book and he and he told
grant that and grant was was very
pleased with say compared it to Caesar's
commentary at the Caesar's commentaries
and I think rightly so did you run to
look at Caesar's commentaries as you do
I have read Caesar's commentaries and
the similarities well Caesar's
commentaries are Latin of course and
this is in English but there is there is
real similarity um
Caesar was very spare in his sentence
structures just the facts
nothing but the facts who moved where
when what they did when they got there
who they fought how they fought them
what the results were what his plans
were boom boom boom boom boom
and if you read grants memoirs it's the
same kind of spare writing this happened
here this happened there and you would
wonder how would be so compelling but
when you read both the commentaries with
it but even more so the memoirs it it
overtakes you it's a it just it moves at
the same pace as the war you know how
it's going to turn out you study the
Civil War you know how every battle is
going to turn out but to be there and
grant and is writing put you there
is it's really an extraordinary reading
experience now is there anything in the
memoir about his presidency very little
very he mentions it in but it's it's
mentioned in passing this is really a
book about Civil War battles go back to
the grant and Ward financial firm how
much money did grant put in in the first
place and why did it go bankrupt and and
do you have any sense of how much money
was lost there were millions lost um
which would be hundreds of millions
hundreds of millions super millions lost
there were banks that were there was a
bank that was bankrupted the head of the
bank was in cahoots with Ferdinand ward
who ran the Furman came up with the idea
through grants son there was some minor
investments there was $50,000 but grants
son father-in-law also put in fifty
thousand dollars so they lost all that
an extraordinary son at the time we go
back to that grant son Fred yes
father-in-law that's right what was that
it was a senator from Nevada and had
made a lot of money and a good deal of
money he was he lost his money but what
was really lost worthy were the paper
profits I mean you know I think one of
the figures is that the at the height of
grant award success grant was worth
$750,000 but it was all on paper none of
it was real they had this was a pyramid
scheme of stock options and certificates
covering certificates and there was no
Securities and Exchange Commission than
these you know this was it was casino
Wall Street was a casino and none of the
all of this was all of this paper was
worthless
how much did the public know about the
bankruptcy well it came out in the press
and there were real criticisms of Brandt
and what he knew and how he knew it and
whether he was part of it he wasn't
there were indictments that were handed
down but not of him because it was it
was clear that he wasn't part of the
fraud he had just lent his name to it
but there is no question that there was
some bad feeling among many people that
he would do this that he would be so
gullible as to be taken in but that was
his
soon it was his culpability it was the
same sin of it as his presidency he
trusted people we thought were his
friends and they turned out to be less
than honest
now you mentioned in the very first part
of this interview that you used to edit
a city paper yes I used to be the editor
so what is the city paper city by sorry
city paper is a weekly here in
Washington I edited it 20 years ago now
but and just starting out as a writer
and journalist and and wrote a piece
about Huckleberry Finn and called Mark
Twain scholars around the country and so
what do you think about this idea that
maybe Grant and Grant had a much greater
influence on the writing of Huckleberry
Finn in' and it had it had been talked
about some but the real relationship and
how it affected each other's writings
had not been written about i kept coming
back to it over the years and finally
three years ago decided to write it up
and where you from a reason i'm from
central wisconsin very small town called
wisconsin rapids in central Wisconsin
where'd you go to college went to I went
to Boston University and in the early
70s and then to graduate school didn't
like graduate school and my wife was a
professor and Dean associate dean here
in Washington DC wanted to come to get
her PhD at Georgetown so I came here and
then I went to Georgetown in the history
program to get a master's in the early
1980s in American history to kind of
hone what I thought were necessary
analytical skills to write American
history other than the city how long
were you the city paper Oh
year and a half two years the most what
have you done since then I've been I was
a freelance reporter for many years
wrote for The Washington Post and The
Daily News in New York st. Louis
post-dispatch but basically in the late
1980s began to write books wrote three
books on national security wrote a book
on the Joint Chiefs of Staff called four
stars book on the CIA called Eclipse
it's a doorstop I wrote a book on the
israeli-palestinian conflict and then
three 19th century histories when the
window
I just I didn't feel comfortable writing
journalism I didn't think that it was
what I should do I was really fascinated
by 19th century America so that's what
I've been doing so this is how you make
your living I am also a political
consultant and this is how I make my
living part of the time and it's it's
good because to make a living as a
writer is a really difficult life and
it's very I think was David Halberstam
said you better have another job well I
do I'm a political consultant and
consult for what-who for a firm in
Washington DC called Jefferson Waterman
International a great firm and it's a
lot of fun and it's a real challenge and
so I come home at night and I dive back
into my history and it took me it takes
two and a half years to to do one of
these week three years and who what kind
of clients do you represent
we represent foreign countries and
American corporations wanting to do
business in foreign countries or foreign
corporations we do business in the
United States and we we know the Middle
Eastern Africa quite well and I travel
extensively in those regions go back to
the book and go back to the end Mount
McGregor you set up earlier near
Saratoga 12 miles from Saratoga and New
York he's sick real sick and got cancer
of the throat and you describe it in the
book how and you know went to his jaw
and all that but what was he in like
quiet grant would rally and fade and
rally and fade and had for months his
doctors thought his writing of his
memoirs was keeping him alive you say he
sat up the entire aadmi and went to
sleep sitting out he went to sleep
sitting up in his chair
he couldn't kind of lie down for some
reason um and it just hurt it hurt to
talk at the end he could just barely
whisper he would he would often write
out instructions or notes on a piece of
paper he did and in his body was wasting
away and and and a day before his death
there's a there's promontory in the
Adirondacks and he and he
he wanted to go up there and he was
lifted in those what was then a bath
chair a wicker chair or a rocking chair
and he was lifted by his family and
friends up in this promontory and stood
there for a moment and got very tired
and sat back down they brought him back
down the mountain and he got up out of
his chair and he laid down of the bed
for the first time in about a year he
laid down in bed and he started to fade
dr. Douglass was there and at I think it
was 819 in the morning of a hot July day
in northern New York he he he died it
was so even though people had expected
it was a great great shock for the
nation where was Mark Twain it was in
Elmira New York and he he wrote in his
journals that he thought that grant
could probably he predicted that grant
could survive for another two or three
months and so he was surprised you say
didn't go to the funeral he didn't he
stood in the he stood in the window of
his offices in the Union Square and
watched the parade odd to me that he
didn't go to the funeral I don't but I
don't think he was comfortable going to
the funeral his his relationship with
grant was not was not military all the
great soldiers of America were there at
the funeral general Han Hancock led they
led the parade and in the group of
mourners between I don't think felt
comfortable he was he was closer to
grant I think in many respects than any
of these men who had followed them how
much money in the ended Mark Twain make
off of grant equivalent to what Julia
made it's not very clear it was 400 to
450 thousand dollars he wrote to William
Dean Howells that he felt like Midas
that he could anything he touched turned
to gold within years however of that he
was going downhill and spending money as
he usually did in in investing in in
inventions that went nowhere what was
the end like for Twain bitter
he was absolutely enthralled with his
daughter Suzie she died enthralled with
his wife
she died he didn't have as much money as
he'd wanted I don't think he understood
how important he was as as an American
writer he didn't look at himself as he
as the Great America writer which he is
and he was he would enjoy a cigar zand
and whiskey with his friends in New York
and traveled to Europe came back to New
York but he's very infirm at the end and
died quietly and what was the biggest
difference between these two men
personally the way they interacted with
one another what were they were they not
alike Twain was outgoing very critical
of others in in many times of his life
and I say this with all due respect him
he could be very nasty he didn't keep
friends long that wasn't true of grant
he met somebody he liked them
and they liked him he was you you don't
ever see grant being nasty he wasn't he
wasn't that way it took each person one
at a time and and gave them their due
you could meet one of the other one or
the other which one would you rather
know grant why grant even though I
admire a twin I'd like I'd like I'd like
to ask grant whether the way that he
fought the Civil War is the way that he
intended to fight it
this man invented the American military
ulysses s grant and I was wondering I
would I'd like to ask him if that was
really his intention what he thought
about his place in history here's the
cover of the book it's grant and Twain
and our guest has been Mark Perry and we
thank you very much my pleasure